I have to say it you're back you're both
back did you think you'd both be back
for another one what was it like to get
you both signed on for this one well it
took a little work on that part for to
bring me back because I just was not
really sure that I had anything more to
say and it's been 28 years and I'm like
are you putting me in a wheelchair or
what because it was just so far-fetched
to come back all these years later but
after careful consideration and vague
outline of the story and thinking I've
got 28 years to fill in with character
and make these decisions and then bring
them to the stage to the sound stage and
I I went for it yeah
see I didn't go through this drama you
know I was much much simpler because Tim
Cameron told me the story after
motorcycle ride and I immediately said
to him I said I mean this is fantastic
especially after they told me that he's
wants to bring back I love that so she
was a big part of it for you yeah I've
been hearing from everybody that you set
the tone on set Linda that you were this
leader and that they all looked up to
you and in your work ethic and what you
brought to the character how fun was it
and also in the hard was it for you to
come back and do this movie well I think
people are being very kind to say that I
set the tone and it was done they all
just got so excited escaping the ladies
are fantastic and I don't think I had
anything to add to their performances
they stood alone and they stood strong
they were
so prepared McKenna I watched Mackenzie
work you know we went to gun camp
together in Texas in
and I was actually feeling a little when
we were in Texas I was just like oh I am
just never gonna be able to not compete
with that but to even match that and you
know she just had so many skills and she
could do a magazine change with her
weapon and a little flip you know all in
one motion and I'm struggling with my
tiny hands too and then to unlearn what
I had learned in 90s in the early 90s
because we don't handle weapons this way
anymore it's now this and it so the more
comfortable I began with the became with
the weapons the more my muscle memory
would make me do the wrong thing and it
was frustrating so I was I was alarmed
but certainly when I show up on set I'm
just all in and they are too by the way
so they're just being kind to me but we
did I think the fact that the three of
us were so committed and really fierce
women and very good actresses if one of
us had been a weak link it all would
have tumbled down you know but we really
elevated each other every day and they
elevated me as much as I elevated them
that's for sure so she can put you in
your place I tell you one thing that
having someone work with you makes you
performance better there's no two ways
about it and I think that I know to play
it down but the reality was as I watched
it firsthand that that obviously the
whole younger team that was on a set
kind of looked at her and saw her
performance and how well she was
prepared and how well she did with the
stunts and how many times she did it
never complained about it so that she
you know raised the bar really high in
1991 with judgement day with the last
Terminator and then now even raised it
higher and so they had no chance but to
go and follow that and try to out a try
to her which she was impossible to do so
that she was a really great motivation
on a set what was it like to hear her
say I'll be back I think was great great
job I wasn't there when she did it but
there was saw it in a movie and I was
amazed that someone could say in a
different way the way I say it and then
I found out that she actually worked on
it to make sure that you could say it in
a different way that you can't say it
without sounding like him yeah I would
finish I would you know it's in the at
the end of a very intense action scene
and it's weapons and it's tripled to
triple digit heat and just given it
everything and then every time I would
finish with that line I would look at
Tam and he would go
sounds like Arnold it again and drop the
grenade and turn around and say it now I
go and you go so did you decide to just
say I'm just gonna say it
her sky Tim guided me through it because
it really was almost impossible to say
it after three decades of hearing it in
your head with his voice by the way we
have a little clip from the judgement
day here you are of course I'm chaste
about t2 because I know it's going to be
the huge big blockbuster of the summer
and it is exciting you know when you
have had last year Total Recall come out
and be you know the big movie of the
summer and then the following year this
year we come out with Terminator 2 and
you have two big chance of making a big
kill again out there so that's exciting
you know I feel very fortunate that I
have great directors that I work with
and it helped me with my career and with
my
with my thumbs did I do it and nothing
has changed because the great directors
this is the bottom line of what I said
the great directors I mean you have a
great director of a chance to really be
successful if you don't have a great
director then your chances are very slim
and this time with Tim Miller be the
great director to actually execute the
vision of Jim Cameron and a great
director and creator Jim Cameron who
created the whole story so we felt very
comfortable with that the package on the
one hand nothing has changed because you
guys are so these talented people making
great choices on the other hand time has
passed what was it like for you to see
each other again and it seems like you
kind of picked things up right clearly
we don't like each other at all
really I was utterly delighted to see
him again yeah flooded with happiness
every every inch of myself so I pretty
much hugged him straight for three the
first three weeks till he's like get off
me it was it was it was fun together
again and as I said she raised the bar
so high in 1991 and so the question was
what is she gonna do in this movie and
she you know kicked some serious ass she
was a badass the the best kind of action
female action hero and you know that at
the age of 60 so that is really okay I
always do that yeah I mean look you guys
killed it in this movie mm-hm and
there's been so many more where
terminators from here will you be back
again only the audience will decide that
okay well I gotta ask you you look we
can never get enough action movies with
you Arnold now you got a son-in-law
who's also a big action star could we
ever get you and Chris Pratt and a movie
together maybe we haven't talked about
it but I mean I respect him very much
I think he's a very dedicated actor and
he trains really hard is in good shape
physically and he's talented so I and
but besides all of that he's great with
my daughter with Captain and that's the
most important part what makes him that
perfect fit it's just a nice man and I'm
saying and so it's always great when
someone is successful and someone has a
vision that someone is driven and knows
where they go in their life so that's
very attractive but if you're not kind
if you know the real Mensch you know
then they don't have much he is a real
kind person and in these terrific with
her well that's got to be tough for you
as a dad to entrust daughter to somebody
else and I would imagine you're kind of
an intimidating father-in-law yes that
can't be yeah it's look we love watching
you guys and I was just talking to
Gabriel and he was saying he worked out
with you for this movie you know I'm
like that must be kind of crazy to be
working out with Arnold Schwarzenegger
and then the girls were telling me that
you quote your own movies which I sort
of loved what of your own movies do you
quote the most well I don't know the
most but I tell you one thing that it
was great working out with Gabriel yeah
because he took it really seriously did
the whole idea that he had to build up
his body is to get the muscular to be
believable on the screen that he can do
and be a real threat to the t800 to my
model and he did a great job he was
smart to ask me a lot of questions and
to train with me in the morning when I
trained which was always between 6:00
and 7:00 in the morning before I went to
the set and then at night a lot of times
when we if we wouldn't would not be that
tired
we would drive back to the hotel and on
the way to the hotel we would stop at
the gym again and work at another half
an hour you know it's it this but he was
just game for anything and for learning
so which was great
you
[Music]